Okay, so in the general mathematical sense that's how we
would optimize the parameters on our model theta by using
batch gradient descent to minimize our cost function, j of
theta. Below is an implementation of linear regression and gradient descent
to try and determine how many lifetime home runs a
player in a baseball data set will hit. Given their height
and weight. I'd encourage you to really look through all
of this code and make sure you understand how it works.
But for now, I'd like you to write some code
here that updates the values of theta a number of
times equal to num_iterations. You should initialize an array called
the cost_history, and every time you've computed the cost for a
given set of thetas You should append it to cost
history. The function should return both the final values of theta
in your theta array, and cost history array. Your code
should go here. Feel free to use other helper functions in
this code, such as compute cost.